>> Tucker: HAS FINALLY BANNED
MEN FROM BEING IN WOMEN'S
SWIMMING EVENTS BUT THERE IS A
CATCH.
THE NEW RULE APPLIES ONLY TO MEN
WHO STARTED TO TRANSITION
WOMANHOOD IF THAT'S POSSIBLE
AFTER THE AGE OF 12 SO THE WORDS
APPEARANCE IS SIZED TO
CHEMICALLY CASTRATE A MALE CHILD
AT A YOUNG AGE THAN THE BODY
WILL ALLOW THAT MAN TO COMPETE
AGAINST WOMEN WHEN THEY GET
OLDER.
WHAT EFFECT DOES THIS CAN HAVE?
SWIM AGAINST LEAH THOMPSON,
THANKS SO MUCH YOU'VE BEEN
ALMOST SINGLE-HANDEDLY BRINGING
THIS TOPIC TO PUBLIC ATTENTION
MANY OF YOUR FELLOW SWIMMERS ARE
EMBARRASSED TO THINK THAT YOU'RE
DOING THIS HEIDI FEEL ABOUT THIS
RULING?
>> I DEFINITELY THINK IT'S A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IT'S A BOLD FIRST STEP OBVIOUSLY
IT'S NOT EVERYTHING WE NEED MORE
ORGANIZATION ACROSS A BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT SPORTS TO COMPLY AS
WELL I THINK A VERY GOOD FIRST
STEP AND SOMETHING WORTH
CELEBRATING.
>> Tucker: DOES THAT REFLECT
OTHER SWIMMERS?
YOU'RE THE SORT OF LENS OR FROM
WE UNDERSTAND SWIMMING AS HE AND
EVERYONE ELSE'S COME ON TV AND
TALK ABOUT IT WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO
AGREE WITH YOU?
>> YES I DO FOR SURE BEING
SOMEONE KNOW WHO IS WITNESS THAT
FIRSTHAND OF THAT COMPETITION IN
MARCH I FOLLOW THE AMOUNT OF
TEARS SHED IN THE LOCKER ROOM
AND THE TALK OF ANGER AND
FRUSTRATION AND SO I DEFINITELY
THINK I'M SPEAKING FOR LARGE
MAJORITY HERE.
>> Tucker: PARENTS AND THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE A LOT OF THEM
CASTRATED SONS TO BE CALLED
MUNICH'S IT WAS HER BENEFIT TO
CASTRATING YOUR CHILDREN IN THE
OTTOMAN EMPIRE, I WONDER IF THIS
RULING DOESN'T SET UP A
POTENTIAL INCENTIVE FOR PARENTS
GIVE THEIR YOUNG BOYS MASSIVE
HORMONE TREATMENTS IN PUBERTY.
>> I THINK IT'S WORTH NOTING
THAT HAVING IT AT THAT AGE WILL
ENCOURAGE PARENTS?
PERSONALLY I THINK IT'S UNLIKELY
BECAUSE I THINK I DON'T HAVE
MUCH EXPERIENCE SEEING THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS.
SO I DO THINK THIS IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION IS
DEFINITELY WORTH THAT STRICT AGE
THAT THEY SAID IT'S A LITTLE
SCARY.
>> Tucker: ASKED QUESTION I AM
ATTACHING TO THIS ABOUT FOUR BUT
WHY HAVEN'T MORE COACHES SPOKEN
OUT ABOUT THIS.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DEVOTED THEIR
LIVES TO SWIMMING AND THEY ARE
GOING ON IN THAT I HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYONE SAY A WORD ABOUT THIS
PUBLICLY WHY?
>> I THINK I WAS TO BE LIVE THIS
CANCEL CULTURE I THINK THEY FEAR
FOR THEIR JOBS THEY HAVE
HIGHER-UPS ABOVE THEM THAT COULD
BE INTIMIDATING THEM UP FRONT
FREE THEM OUT.
I THINK THEY'RE AFRAID TO SPEAK
OUT ABOUT IT BUT THE MORE VOICES
WITH A BE ATHLETES OR COACHES OR
NONATHLETES IT REALLY JUST A
MATTER TO HAVE THOSE VOICES IT
REALLY HELPS OUT A LOT.
>> T